Sometimes, an actor becomes so intrinsically
associated with a movie character that it's
very difficult to imagine anyone else occupying
that screen space.
In the case of these castings, the actors
were so right for their roles that it seems
completely wrong that they weren't the first
ones the filmmakers had in mind.
Here are some actors who almost didn't get
their very memorable parts.
Gene Wilder
While he's best remembered for his iconic
performance as Willy Wonka, Gene Wilder also
collaborated with director Mel Brooks on a
series of classic comedies, such as The Producers,
Young Frankenstein, and most famously, Blazing
Saddles.
This 1974 satire was a savage takedown of
both the Western genre and race relations
in America, and it featured Wilder as the
Waco Kid, a drunken gunfighter who decides
to help Sheriff Bart face down racist townsfolk
and an evil gang of cowboys, bikers, and German
soldiers.
But while Wilder now seems like such an obvious
guy to play the part, Brooks originally wanted
an older actor, somebody who "could look like
an over-the-hill alcoholic."
He considered going after Dan Dailey — an
actor best known for starring in old-timey
musicals — and thought about casting talk
show host Johnny Carson.
Brooks even asked John Wayne to read the script.
And while the Duke thought it was hysterical,
he said he couldn't play in a movie "that
had such low-down dirty talk" — even though
he did promise to be the "the first one in
line to see it."
"I won't?
The hell I won't."
Eventually, Brooks hired Gig Young, but he
had to drop out, ironically, because of his
problems with alcohol.
Desperate, Brooks finally decided to cast
Wilder — who'd been asking to play the part
for a while, and the rest is cinematic history.
Ed Harris
In 1998, Jim Carrey gave one of his best performances
to date in The Truman Show, but he wasn't
the only one bringing his A-game to Peter
Weir's brilliant take on TV, celebrity, and
religion.
Ed Harris also created a memorable role in
Christof, the all-powerful director who sits
in his moon base and controls every detail
of Truman's life.
But while Harris was perfect in the role,
he actually didn't get the part until two
months after shooting started — and that's
because Christof was actually meant to be
played by a different Hollywood legend.
Best known for his performances in movies
like Easy Rider, Apocalypse Now, Blue Velvet,
and Hoosiers, Dennis Hopper was the man originally
cast as Christof, but he didn't last very
long.
Speaking with writer Alex Godfrey, Hopper
said he "was on the set for like, two days,
and got fired … Scott Rudin, the producer,
had made an agreement with the director [Peter
Weir] that… if he didn't like what I did
after the first day's dailies then he would
fire me.
And they fired me."
Although it was an insult to Hopper, it also
put Ed Harris in a tough spot, as he started
shooting just days after signing onto the
project.
Harris later revealed, "I didn't have much
time to prepare, but it worked out all right.
In fact, it was almost a blessing in disguise,
because I was forced to trust my instincts."
"Good afternoon, good evening, and good night."
Clint Eastwood
Directed by Sergio Leone, A Fistful of Dollars
is the movie that kickstarted Clint Eastwood's
career as the whispering, no-nonsense, squinty-eyed
action hero that we've all come to know.
But back in the early '60s, Eastwood was just
a lowly TV actor and nowhere close to the
top of the list when it came to casting choices.
In fact, Leone offered the role of the Man
with No Name to pretty much every actor in
Hollywood before giving the job to Eastwood.
He went after guys you've probably never heard
of, like Rory Calhoun, Henry Silva, and Eric
Fleming.
He also tried to lure in bigger names like
Henry Fonda, Charles Bronson, and James Coburn,
but they all shot down his proposal, mainly
over money.
Leone could only pay $15,000, which wasn't
much for an established star.
Fortunately, the Italian director saw an episode
of the TV show Rawhide which featured a young
Eastwood as Rowdy Yates, a naïve, immature
cowboy who's a whole lot friendlier than the
Man with No Name.
Despite the differences, Leone thought Eastwood
was, quote, "good at getting on a horse."
Soon enough, Eastwood was one of the biggest
movie stars in history, all thanks to a corny
TV show and a bunch of overpaid actors.
Casey Affleck
In the critically-acclaimed film Manchester
by the Sea, Casey Affleck plays Lee Chandler,
a man struggling with grief and guilt in the
aftermath of a terrible tragedy, and he totally
owns the part.
In fact, he won an Academy Award for his work
with the role in 2017.
But it was actually long-time Affleck family
friend Matt Damon who was initially supposed
to star in the role.
The film's plot was originally dreamed up
by Damon and John Krasinski of The Office,
and they asked filmmaker Kenneth Lonergan
to write the script.
Damon intended to direct and star, but it
took Lonergan three years to write the first
draft.
When he was done, Damon didn't have time to
direct.
He still wanted to play the main character,
but when other projects got in the way, he
passed the role of Lee to Affleck.
"Yeah, he passes on all the good ones."
Damon told The Hollywood Reporter, "This is
one of the best roles I've ever seen for a
leading actor.
I didn't want to hand it off to somebody unless
that was somebody I grew up with and who would
make me happy I gave it up."
All that work and all he got was one lousy
shoutout.
"Thank you also to Matt Damon for creating
this opportunity."
Jodie Foster and Kristen Stewart
Sandwiched in between Fight Club and Zodiac,
Panic Room is a film that's often forgotten
when discussing David Fincher films.
And really, that's too bad, as the 2002 film
is a solid thriller featuring strong performances
from its two female leads, Jodie Foster and
Kristen Stewart.
The two play a mom and daughter taking shelter
inside, well, a panic room after a trio of
thieves breaks into their home.
But while both actresses do a great job, neither
were the original picks for this gritty suspense
film.
Fincher has revealed that the first actress
chosen for the part of the daughter, Sarah,
was, quote, "very feminine and girlish and
all those things, and just irritated [him]
beyond belief."
Fincher hasn't mentioned the actress by name,
but Hayden Panettiere was reportedly booked
to play Sarah, but dropped out shortly before
filming started.
Fincher then went with Stewart after seeing
both an audition tape and a commercial featuring
the young girl, saying he liked her "tomboy-ish,
androgynous quality."
As for the role of Meg, the mom, the part
originally went to Nicole Kidman, and she
was actually working on the movie for about
two weeks before injuring her knee.
Evidently, the pain was so bad that she was
forced to pull out of Panic Room.
Fortunately for Fincher, Jodie Foster saved
the day, taking the lead role and getting
production moving again.
Interestingly, casting Foster changed the
director's entire vision for the film.
Talking to The Guardian, Fincher explained
that Kidman was all about "glamour and physicality,"
like Grace Kelly in a Hitchcock film, while
with Foster, "it's more about what happens
in her eyes.
It's more political."
Vin Diesel
The Fast and the Furious franchise is full
of memorable characters, but Dominic Toretto
is the centerpiece of the series.
This street-racing criminal who puts family
above all else has appeared in every entry
in the series except one, and he's basically
the chassis of the whole Fast and Furious
universe.
Nowadays, it's virtually impossible to think
of anyone besides Vin Diesel playing the part
of Dom because he is the face of the franchise.
But as you've probably guessed by now, Diesel
wasn't number one on the list of actors to
try out for Toretto.
Producer Neal H. Moritz has since revealed
that while actor Paul Walker was Brian from
the get-go, studio executives were keen to
cast Timothy Olyphant as Dom.
However, for unknown reasons, he passed on
the part.
Seeing Olyphant as Dom would've been interesting,
but picking Diesel was obviously the right
choice.
The first Fast and the Furious earned $207
million on a $38 million budget, and the series
has become one of the top-ten highest-grossing
franchises of all-time, largely thanks to
Diesel's star power.
"The street always wins."
So yeah, it looks like the studio executives
at Universal eventually chose the right man
for the job.
Emma Stone and Ryan Gosling
Sure, La La Land didn't actually win the Oscar
for Best Picture, but it did win the hearts
of audiences around the world, largely thanks
to the winning duo of Emma Stone and Ryan
Gosling.
But if things had played out a little bit
differently, an entirely different Emma would've
been dancing across the silver screen.
The same goes for Gosling, who got the call
to play jazz pianist Sebastian when writer-director
Damien Chazelle decided to change his original
acting line-up.
Originally, La La Land would have starred
Emma Watson and Miles Teller.
Back in early 2015, Damien Chazelle said the
only thing he knew for sure about La La Land
was that it would be a musical, and that Teller
would play the male lead.
The two had previously worked together on
his critically acclaimed film Whiplash, so
the reunion made sense.
But a whole lot can happen when you're working
on a movie, especially one you started writing
back in 2010.
Along the way, La La Land began to evolve,
and Chazelle eventually decided that Teller
wasn't right for the part after all.
Unfortunately, the young actor didn't take
the news very well, texting the director, "what the f---, bro?"
Emma Watson reportedly handled things a lot
better, and she was okay with passing on the
part of Mia.
After all, she was already committed to Disney's
live-action reboot of Beauty and the Beast,
and as she explained to Entertainment Weekly,
"I knew I had horse training.
I knew I had dancing, I knew I had three months
of singing ahead of me, and I knew I had to
be in London to really do that….
So scheduling conflict-wise, it just didn't
work out."
Of course, Watson's Beauty and the Beast went
on to break the billion dollar barrier, becoming
one of the highest grossing films ever made,
and Stone would win an Oscar for her La La
Land performance as Mia.
So yeah, it looks like things worked out pretty
well for both of the Emmas.
As for Teller, well, he's probably still nursing
a case of whiplash over the director's diss
and dismissal.
James McAvoy
When M. Night Shyamalan's Split hit theaters
in early 2017, audiences were terrified by
James McAvoy's performance as Kevin… and
Patricia… and Hedwig… and Dennis.
Playing a man with 23 personalities — and
a 24th on the way — McAvoy stole the show
every time he morphed into a new persona.
But as it turns out, Joaquin Phoenix, who'd
worked with the director on Signs, was actually
Shyamalan's first choice to play Kevin and
each of his individual identities.
However, Phoenix ended up being tied to another
movie and had to drop out.
Making things even more complicated, Shyamalan's
second choice, McAvoy, was also committed
to another film.
Fortunately for everyone involved with Split,
the Scottish actor's schedule soon cleared
up, and he was able to sign on.
But stepping into the film so suddenly posed
a bit of a challenge for McAvoy, since he
had to play nine different characters.
As as a result of the casting confusion, he
only had "about a quarter of the time" that
he usually took to prepare for just one character,
let alone nine.
Still, McAvoy was able to pull the roles off
perfectly, scaring audiences and critics alike.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!